speaking of Elon Musk what do you guys
think of his Twitter acquisition I was
just going to say he should accept Shiba
Inu for the Eight dollar a month thing
and that's how we can uh we can produce
the value of it yeah
um or maybe he'll offer like a discount
and say pay and she been yeah you get
your blue check for five or something
like that
but that whole like verification system
doesn't make a lot of sense I mean
people are going to pay for it just
because it's eight bucks and they get a
blue check mark and you get the thing
that I like about it is you can upload
longer videos so I could potentially
take the videos that I make for my
channel and upload them over there as
well and then it's native on the
platform because whenever you link to a
video on YouTube on something like um
Twitter they don't give it the same
reach that you'll get if you um natively
upload it to the site so that's really
the only thing that I'm interested in
but I but I checked that I couldn't do
it because you can only do it on iOS
right now they haven't made it available
for browser or for Android
I wonder if he's going to come out
was that drugs
it's already being abused yeah yeah like
you'll get uh people paying eight
dollars and some wacky [ __ ] credit
card and wacky account that'll still
troll
yeah they kind of made it like some dirt
on this insulin reduction
uh company they made a fake Twitter
account saying that insulin would be
free and the stock for that particular
company dropped
um
well if anybody's gonna fix social media
it'll be Elon Musk I don't trust Zucker
anybody else to do it
the robots how many people do you end up
firing something like 50 of the staff
there's a large chunk yeah yeah
something like 3 700 right it's fairly
more because it would have been hard to
keep operating with less than half
let me check here and more are going to
be changed
how many Twitter
stuff
uh hang on here we lose
uh
who the hell did we lose oh okay we'll
click when he comes back 3 700 people
from Twitter
almost half it says we're here almost
half its staff is that all they have
I thought they had 20 000 employees for
some reason but laying off half the
staff well that's what you need to do
well they're not as like complex as
YouTube or anything I don't think they
need as many coders or
from from what I understand musk is is
planning on making it more than just
like micro blogging because that's what
Twitter was set up as initially was a
microblock site
um but from what I understand the way
that he's been talking about it is
there's going to be more offerings I
mean even with the blue check system you
know you've got access to upload longer
videos you know your tweets show towards
the top if it's a app reply
um so that's yeah okay maybe you can
turn into a YouTube competitor
that would be cool yeah that would be
cool because like what's the other one
Rumble that they were trying to do it's
just not as functional it's hard to it's
hard to navigate yeah there's wrong yeah
yeah we'll see what happens I mean you
know it's like super Geeks like Elon
Musk will fix stuff like this I think
all right
um let me grab this YouTube link over
here and see if I can make this Twitter
Twitter just uh applied for becoming a
money transferring
payment processor
I'm not sure if it's money transfers or
Payment Processing like they need
different things in different parts of
the world he's going back
they all technically kind of do that I
always remember that when I look at my
Apple pay thinking well this money's
sitting in a balance somewhere Apple's
technically a bank across this entire
user base and has who knows what in
their Apple pay account because I think
all these companies are doing it Elon
started PayPal right that was his first
thing he was one of the founders yeah
yeah along with Peter Thiel and a bunch
of the other um
PayPal Squad I'm loving Elon on Twitter
I think it's a lot it's it's become way
more fun than it's ever been I think
that's a lot of people are going on
there for entertainment and watching him
actually interact and like
clapping such a troll yeah yeah he
really is at his core like that's what
but what's really really interesting is
he's always been this way and if you
like every now and then somebody will
tweet out or like some of these public
texts some of these text messages or
emails that he has between like
employees and different folks will get
leaked and he's just such a no-nonsense
guy he's just like what have you gotten
done how much work have you like
finished what this is not worth my time
or attention he actually was pitched
this FTX guy
recently and he made a comment he was
like oh I was told this guy was worth
like three billion liquid and I don't
buy it and I didn't buy it and my red
flags came up so this whole FTX guy he
was he was uh he was somebody was trying
to broker an intro but how he really
wants to work with you and this and that
Elon was like yeah I don't [ __ ] buy
it so that I just thought that was
pretty interesting
um
that you know whatever reason people
like to dunk on him I think he's
hilarious like I think he's kind of the
the Court Jester that we all need but
he's also like a freaking genius so I've
I've seen his prior emails
um to staff and I and I tend to agree
he's he's very direct he's a he's a
brilliant entrepreneur I mean like one
thing that I learned from him a long
time ago was
um
he had this email to his staff and he
was like basically uh something along
the lines of
um if I give you Direction you either
follow it you provide me with a better
solution or you [ __ ] off basically and I
was like that is [ __ ] clear like that
is as clear as it gets that's the way
that you want to run things none of this
um you know let me address your whatever
[ __ ] woke new thing so I found an
article here that says read Elon musk's
first email to all Twitter employees
remote work over a company needs
subscriptions to subscribe downturn
let's see what he has to say here if
there's a
link here to it okay here we go from
Elon Musk to team uh sorry this is my
first email to the whole company but
there is no way to sugarcoat the message
frankly the economic picture ahead is
dire especially for the company like
ours that is so dependent on advertising
in a challenging economic climate
moreover 70 percent of our advertising
is brand rather than specific
performance which makes us doubly
vulnerable that is why the priority over
the past 10 days has been to develop and
launch Twitter blue verified
subscriptions so he's getting eight
dollars per subscriber on this which is
pretty clever I mean it's like it's like
Netflix or Disney Plus or whatever right
without significant subscription Revenue
there's a good chance Twitter will not
survive the up the upcoming economic
downturn we need roughly half of our
Revenue I'll be happy to give them eight
bucks I don't give a [ __ ] you know of
course we will then be significantly
reliant on Advertising so I'm spending
our time with our sales and Partnerships
teams to ensure the Twitter continues to
be an appealing place to advertisers
um this is in the spaces discussion that
Robin you all and I hosted today linked
a q a advertising future removed the
road ahead is arduous and will require
intense work to succeed we're also
changing Twitter's policy such that
remote work is no longer allowed at
least unless you have a specific
exemption so all these [ __ ] guys that
got comfortable working from home
they're basically not coming back
managers will send the exception list
for me for review and approval so the
exception list goes directly to the CEO
of Twitter like that's unheard of right
um starting tomorrow Thursday everyone
is required to be in the office for a
minimum of 40 apps starting tomorrow
10 days noted that's the control to
notice your ass in the office
um you also apparently like he called an
all hands meeting with an hour notice he
just like sent out a memo that was like
Hey everybody get to wherever like and
then he was 15 minutes late
oh yeah and he showed 15 minutes after
the fact like just so fun and it's just
you gotta love this guy plugged in beta
when it comes to like girls right
he doesn't have like a bunch of kids
with a bunch of different women he does
he actually he's actually had 10
children let me get to that in a second
though let me just finish reading this
because I'm in the last uh paragraph uh
starting tomorrow Thursday everyone is
required to be in the office for a
minimum of 40 hours per week obviously
if you're physically unable to travel
two and off officer have a critical
personal obligation then your absence is
understandable I look forward to working
with you to take Twitter as a whole new
level the potential is truly incredible
thanks Gila so yeah he's um I did a
video a long time ago a couple years ago
like two three years ago
um when
um what's his name the dude that did um
the game and the truth about
relationships yeah Strauss so Neil
Strauss did an interview with him I
think for Rolling Stone magazine or GQ
or something like that and um and I kind
of went through the article it's on my
channel somewhere and kind of broke down
what was going on because he was because
he was basically on the ground crying
about a breakup with um
Amber Heard because he was dating Amber
Heard at the time that psychopath that
you know Johnny Depp just dealt with you
know the last 12 months
yeah and um and there was a lot of clear
evidence that like he doesn't know how
to deal with women or rejection which is
fine because I mean you guys like dudes
on the Spectrum he's a weapon when it
comes to business he's a weapon when it
comes to like solving big problems he's
a great entrepreneur like I fully
respect him in that regard uh Elon if
you're watching you know if you want to
hop on a call I'm happy to chat with you
to sort your [ __ ] head out and square
it away properly but
um yeah he's had 10 kids apparently uh I
think one of them he lost either uh
stillborn or uh shortly after birth but
he's but he's reproduced like nine
10 times with several women and I think
one of the most hilarious one was that
lady that used to work for him
um
and I think it was simultaneously when
um Grimes was just like like within the
last 90 days of her giving birth to his
second kid
Brian's you know there's a [ __ ]
problem like right there why would you
get I don't know hey family you know
here's my check Grimes you know Grimes
this is everybody
oh
could you imagine that at Thanksgiving
did he have a kid with the cleaning lady
no he didn't no not yet oh that's Arnold
not yet anyway but that's Arnold it's
coming
hey guys I really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out